chinese state media is reporting that
nine
miners bodies were removed from a mine
shaft after being trapped underground
for two weeks
eleven others were rescued alive an
explosion at the gold mine in shandong
province blocked the exit and cut them
off from the outside world
the men were lifted out of the mine
through a ventilation shaft over the
weekend
most of them were able to survive on
food and medical supplies
sent to them by rescue workers while
they were trapped
we're joined now by journalist fabian
kretschmer in beijing who's been
following this story for us
fabian nine miners are now confirmed
dead state media says that
please bring us up to date with how that
rescue operation went
yeah the nine miners they were found out
to be dead today but we already know
from before that one other miner is also
dead so in total
10 miners have died and there are only
chances that
one could be still alive so out of the
22 and
one is still trapped alive or not alive
this we don't know because um
his whereabouts are still unknown but
the 11 rescued miners from yesterday
they are in relatively stable conditions
except for one who is in a very weak
condition
yeah and that is uh at least some very
good news that those 11 miners were
rescued
um with that one minor that's been
unaccounted for
what hope do rescuers have that he'll be
found alive
well there's no communication with him
there was
also no um additional food deliveries we
know that the ten miners who've been
rescued um among the 11 they were sent
um
food and that was really um they could
survive without any problem but
um until yesterday there was also one
miner who was actually rescued by chance
and he also
survived for 14 days without food so
it's possible that even
15 days now after the miners were
trapped the last remaining could be safe
but
i mean time is running out and we don't
really know exactly where he's located
so i would say the chance of survival
are rather low at this point
mine safety is a problem in china
according to official numbers the
country recorded almost
600 mine related deaths in 2020 why is
safety so bad there
i mean there's it's really a combination
of reasons but i would say the main
reason is that
safety standards which are actually um
yeah in law they are really not enforced
especially in
provincial areas and that companies put
profits over human safety and also what
happened here in this
case there was an explosion and the
company didn't report it for over 13
30 hours to the authorities because they
were fearing a negative
consequences for their own uh career
they tried to solve it by their own but
in
in in the end those is really a precious
time for the um
for the uh rescue mission which in the
end was lost so it's really
a very systematic problem all right
fabian krichman in beijing thanks very
much for the update